the mystery of Jeffrey Epstein's
apparent suicide may be deepening with
new information from the jail where the
accused sex trafficker died Attorney
General William bar has reassigned the
warden in charge of that jail in
Manhattan and two staffers who were
responsible for watching Epstein were
placed on leave mola legi is outside the
Metropolitan Correctional Center molla
what our source is telling you
well good morning guys CBS News has
learned that unreleased video allegedly
shows some of the guards here at the
Metropolitan Correctional Center it did
not make some of the checks on Jeffrey
Epstein that not only were they supposed
to make but that they had logged and
documented before his death now the FBI
is starting to ask some of the prison
staff exactly how this could have
happened this has multiple
investigations federal probes
intensifying we've also learned that at
least two of the prison correctional
officers here have lawyered up a law
enforcement source with knowledge of the
investigation tell CBS News corrections
officers may have falsified reports that
they completed required check-ins on
Jeffrey Epstein and he was left
unmonitored for at least two hours CBS
News has learned the day before
Epstein died his cellmate posted bail
leaving the disgraced financier alone in
his cell in the special housing unit and
now the FBI wants to review footage of
the area where Epstein was held it's
unclear how he allegedly hanged himself
this is just not acceptable attorney
Gloria Allred represents several epstein
accusers during a press conference
Tuesday she criticized the detention
center and I'm tired of the system
failing women and they failed these
victims these child victims on Capitol
Hill there are now multiple inquiries
into Epstein's death
and the investigation into his alleged
sex crimes is also expanding earlier
this week FBI agents raided Epstein's
private island in the Caribbean
reportedly season computers it's unclear
who will gain control of Epstein's
estate his younger brother mark is
reportedly a possible beneficiary and is
affiliated with the company that owns
the New York apartment complex were
Epstein allegedly housed young models
Allred says her clients intend to file
civil cases against Epstein's estate
once it is opened even though he is
deceased the victims need to be
compensated for their medical bills for
the therapy bills for their pain and
suffering well during that press
conference that you just heard right
there Gloria Allred the attorney was
asked if her clients planned to sue the
British socialite and ex-girlfriend of
Jeffrey Epstein ghilane Maxwell of
course Maxwell is accused by some of
peps teens alleged victims of recruiting
girls for Epstein those are charges
those are allegations that Maxwell has
vehemently denied she has not been
charged in any crimes in response Allred
said that we will follow the evidence
she also added that there were a lot of
famous names that were involved with
Epstein Tony all right mola thank you
very much